Aiaia! Aiaia!
Aiaia!
seating
N-n-n-n-nice!
N-n-n-n-n-nice!
Ist das Firestorm? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ja, das muss Firestorm sein. Ich hab Firestorm nie gespielt.
Firestorm, Alter.
Keg W
Warum sind die Amis eigentlich, oder was heißt die Amis, warum ist das im Englischen eigentlich so bescheuert,
dass jeder Buchstabe schön kurz ist, aber W, W wird dann W ausgeholt, so ewig lang.
Das verwirrt die Leute auch. Kennt ihr die Leute in CS, die dann statt AWP sagen die AWP und sowas, das ist doch vollkommen logisch,
weil das der einzige Buchstabe ist, der so kacke ist.
Das hätten die mal ordentlich nennen müssen. Ich bin dafür, die sollten das jetzt quasi retroaktiv umbenennen,
dass das jetzt in Zukunft nicht mehr W ausgesprochen wird. Kannst doch keiner merken.
Im Spanischen auch. Da haben die es auch nicht mal. Ich mein wir sind auch nicht besser, ich mein Y.
Y, wer hat sich das ausgedacht, das ist doch Usability Nightmare.
Deswegen sagen ja auch die cleveren Leute in CS, oder jetzt in Valorant ja auch, das ist eigentlich ganz lustig,
die sagen ja AWP, weil die keinen Bock haben auf AWP.
Und ich hab noch keinen gehört, der in irgendwelchen Valorant Streams die Sniper wirklich so,
ich weiß gar nicht wie die Sniper in dem Game heißt. Die nennen die alle wie die CS Sniper.
Die Griechen haben sich das ausgedacht, die Griechen haben viele komische Dinge gemacht.
Die heißt Operator, okay. Hab ich noch nie gehört, sagt keiner.
Ich hab übrigens immer noch nicht gespielt, aber ich gucke in letzter Zeit relativ viel Valorant Streams,
weil ich das ganz interessant zum zugucken finde. Die meisten Leute, gerade bei Overwatch Streamern,
sind ja voll am rumheulen. Die sagen immer nur Valorant, Resident Slipper, Overwatch POC,
wo ich mir denke Overwatch war seit zwei Jahren immer POC. Das war jetzt ein typischer Twitch Satz, oder?
Overwatch war seit zwei Jahren nicht mal POC. Das versteht außerhalb von Twitch nur wirklich keiner.
Ich frag mich eh was mit Overwatch los ist. Das ist komplett, komplett dead mittlerweile.
Das ist komplett, komplett hinüber. Wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt, Twitch.
Ja nein, ich will nicht meinen eigenen Stream aufmachen. Nicht View Button.
Guckt euch mal hier, jede Menge Valorant Gelaber, wo wir jetzt auch mittlerweile dazu zählen.
Ach, spielst du wieder? Ich dachte du hast jetzt noch mal kurz angeguckt.
Ja es gibt Ranks seit zwei Tagen oder drei Tagen oder so.
Und wo bist du eingerankt worden, falls du noch da bist? Ich rate mal, ich rate mal.
Ich sag du bist Diamond 1 oder 2.
Gold 1, POC, dann mach dir nix draus. Siegal ist glaube ich Iron 3 oder sowas.
Guckt euch mal an, wo ist hier Overwatch?
Ich meine sogar Fortnite ist mittlerweile nicht mal auf dem ersten Platz.
Dafür kommt jetzt Battle Royale Cod Geschichten.
Und irgendwo hier kommt dann Overwatch jetzt. Wo ist es?
Immer noch kein Overwatch. Hab ich es übersehen oder ist es einfach wirklich so weit unten?
Ich hab es bestimmt übersehen, oder?
Hier, Overwatch, da.
Ja ich hab mich ja nicht an das neue Bild gewöhnt.
Der Held sieht auch richtig, gefällt mir überhaupt nicht.
Ich meine, okay es ist eine gute Gesellschaft mit Apex Legends, die haben es auch verkackt.
Aber hier, das ist weit, weit, weit von dem vorbei.
Ich mein, ihr müsst euch mal angucken.
Overwatch hat ungefähr genauso viele Viewer wie Oldschool DroneScape.
Das stimmt, die Drops machen viel aus, aber die anderen Games oben haben keine Drops.
Was geht mit den Leuten ab, ey?
Jump King.
Ich kann nicht, dass das überhaupt noch Leute spielen.
Ich dachte, das wäre so was wie Getting Over, etwas nach zwei Monaten keinem interessiert.
POE.
Irgendwie sind die Blizzard-Spiele außer Hearthstone.
Hearthstone ist glaube ich immer noch ganz gut dabei.
Und wow, ein bisschen am abscheißen, ne?
MapleStory ist ein Game von Zebaro, aber eindeutig.
Blizzard ist auch nicht mal das, was sie früher waren, nach Black Fire.
Schon lange nicht mehr.
Das letzte, was war denn das letzte?
Das letzte gute Game, was Blizzard rausgebracht hat, war schon Overwatch.
Kann man nichts sagen.
Overwatch war nicht schlecht.
Die hatten bloß irgendwie keinen Plan, was sie mit dem Game machen sollten, hatte ich den Eindruck.
Sie hatten große Ambitionen und einen Businessplan irgendwie, aber keinen Content- und Gamingplan so wirklich.
Ja, das ist a real winner.
Es ist tatsächlich so, wenn da nicht ein großer streamt bei Overwatch hier, ist das komplett dead.
Ich hatte es auch letztens gesehen, da war aber kein großer on.
Da hatte Overwatch glaube ich 1200 oder 1300 Zuschauer.
Oder noch weniger.
Das war voll am Arsch.
Das habe ich gar nicht gefunden, deswegen habe ich immer auch so weit runtergescrollt.
Wenn nicht ein paar große online sind, ist es vorbei.
Ja, bis sehr nirgends.
Ja, und das ist alles, was ich sehe, was sie halt bei Overwatch irgendwie verkackt haben.
Das letzte gute Game, was sie rausgebracht haben, ist meiner Meinung nach schon Overwatch.
Das war nicht schlecht, hatten halt keinen Plan.
Aber ansonsten, so wirklich Games...
Ich meine, die haben sogar Warcraft 3 wieder verkackt.
So wirklich, das wirklich richtig...
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Frage.
Manche sagen, dass CSGO dead ist.
CSGO ist so groß wie selten zuvor, aber die Leute, für die ist alles dead.
Overwatch ist ja auch nicht dead, im eigentlichen Sinne.
Es ist bloß im Vergleich zu dem, wie es früher gewesen ist, komplett unbedeutend geworden.
Und wenn man sogar sieht, dass...
Dass jetzt sogar Sinatra, also der...
Was war er?
Bester Spieler der letzten Overwatch-League-Season?
Dass der jetzt gewechselt ist...
Zu einer anderen Organisation, zu Sentinels.
Und Valorant spielt, sagt nicht sonderlich viel Gutes über Overwatch.
Ja, Overwatch.
Die haben es ja bis heute nicht geschafft.
Ich muss jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter über Overwatch ablässern.
Die haben es ja bis heute nicht geschafft irgendwie.
Das Spiel halbwegs zu balancen, das ist auch schwer.
Und das Blizzard ist ja bekannt dafür.
Das Blizzard immer übertrieben nerft und dann übertrieben bufft und irgendwie nichts auf die Reihe kriegt.
Ist nicht so, dass andere Spiele nicht auch das Problem hätten.
Aber Overwatch, haben sie es irgendwie, haben sie nie so richtig die Kurve gekriegt.
Der zweite Teil wirkt für mich auch irgendwie sehr halbherzig.
Interessiert sich überhaupt irgendjemand für Overwatch 2?
Nee, Overwatch 2 wird glaub ich gar nicht großartig was ändern.
Kann ich mir, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Und die haben halt teilweise ultra lang gebraucht, um was zu machen.
Ich mein, überlegt es euch mal, in einer Zeit, wo hier, auch wenn ich jetzt kein großer Fortnite-Fan bin,
in einer Zeit, wo Fortnite irgendwie 15 Sachen rausgebracht hat,
mit aktuellem Bezug, sei es irgendwie, was man sieht, Thanos-Patches und sonst was, was am Anfang übelst gehypt war,
haben die ja irgendwie, Fortnite hat 15 Sachen rausgehauen.
Da hat es Overwatch geschafft, in der gleichen Zeit, mal nen Comic zu releasen.
Noch nicht mal irgendwie was zu machen, die haben dann so 12 Seiten Comic releaset.
In der Zeit, wo Fortnite 15 Patches gekriegt hat, so nach dem Motto.
Das haben sie halt voll verkackt, ja.
Das Gleiche auch, dass du dir teilweise manche Sachen für ein halbes Jahr geben musst,
die absolut unspaßig und Bullshit-mäßig waren.
Ich hatte ja keinen Bock mehr, also abschließend keinen Bock mehr,
wo das ganze Nahkampf-Tankmeter am Start war.
So mit Brigitte-Stun und sowas.
Das war mir zu doof, wo ich mir gedacht habe, ist das jetzt noch ein Shooter,
oder ist das irgendwie so ein Melee-Brawler, oder was ist das?
Jeff Kaplan ist der unfil... Nee, das kann man...
Ich weiß, ich bin mir da ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so ganz sicher,
inwieweit man da wem irgendwie was in die Schuhe schieben kann.
Das ist normalerweise bei Ubisoft, ja.
Nee, nicht bei Ubisoft, bei Bethesda hast du da den Typ,
ich weiß nicht wie er heißt, der Fallout-Mensch,
der immer vor der Kamera steht, über den haten sie ja alle.
Der hat das aber bestimmt nicht alles alleine getroffen.
Da hast du wenigstens irgendwie so ein Feinbild.
Todd Howard, genau den meine ich.
Aber bei Overwatch irgendwie nicht so, weil Chef mag eigentlich jeder.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es immer die beste Idee ist, auf die Community zu hören.
Das Problem, was Blizzard allgemein hat, ist...
Jetzt mal unabhängig von Overwatch.
Das, was Blizzard allgemein hat, Blizzard ist der Meinung,
dass sie komplett die Weißheit mit Löffel gefressen haben
und alle anderen sind Kacknoobs, um nicht zu sagen scheiß Kacknoobs.
Guckt euch mal an, wie lang hat Blizzard gebraucht...
Wie lang hat Blizzard gebraucht, WoW Classic zu machen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob WoW Classic jetzt immer noch Cues hat und sonst was.
Es war auf jeden Fall erfolgreich, so viel kann man sagen.
Du wolltest doch Titanfall 2, das ist richtig.
WoW Classic war auf jeden Fall erfolgreich.
Ob das jetzt jahrelanger Erfolg ist, sei mal dahingestellt.
WoW Classic ist definitiv ein Erfolg.
Wie lang und wie viel Überzeugungsarbeit hat es gebraucht,
bis Blizzard sich mal dazu erbarmt hat, WoW Classic zu machen?
Und sie haben es ja auch nur gemacht irgendwann,
weil wahrscheinlich ihnen die Leute zu sehr auf den Sack gingen
und sie haben hier selbst gar nicht so richtig dran geglaubt.
Das hast du am Anfang auch gesehen mit Server-Clustern und sonst was.
Und jetzt kam das ganze Rauch und hat gesagt,
Huch, fuck aller, die Leute spielen das ja.
Ich finde an WoW Classic sieht man ziemlich gut,
dass Blizzard der Ansicht ist, sie haben wirklich die Weißheit
komplett mit Löffel gefressen, alles andere sind scheiß Kacknoobs.
Das ist für mich auch nicht immer die beste Idee, rein auf die Community zu hören.
Wenn man die Community in Reinform erleben will,
muss man sich mal die Kommentare unter Call of Duty Videos
oder auf YouTube angucken.
Das, was die meisten Leute schreiben, ist komplett hirnverbrannt.
Oder auch bei allen anderen Games.
Aber was man meiner Meinung nach hätte mehr machen müssen,
oder was gerade Blizzard bei allen ihren Games mehr machen müsste,
sie müssten auf die Leute hören, die das professionell,
bzw. die da mit ihr Geld verdienen.
Das haben die bei Fortnite gemacht, da kannst du nichts sagen.
Ja, ich sage klar, Blizzard hat mehr auf die Leute hören müssen.
Vor allem auf die, die Plan vom Game haben.
Ich habe Dota 2 nie gespielt, muss ich gleich mal einen Disclaimer sagen.
Ich bin ja auch nicht der MOBA-Bro.
Allerdings muss es ja bei... Spielt jemand Dota 2 von euch?
Allerdings muss es ja bei Dota 2 so sein, dass immer noch,
was Balancing angeht und sonst was, das eines der besten Games ist, die es gibt.
Und unter anderem deswegen, weil immer noch...
Wie heißt der denn der Ober-Dotamann?
Weil immer noch einer der Erfinder der ursprünglichen Sache mit am Start ist.
Was ist das für ein Video?
Ice-Block, genau, Ice-Block.
Was ist das? Warum ist das 19 Sekunden lang?
Yes, of course, Father, I'm always studying.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes...
What the fuck?
Was zum Scheißen soll das jetzt gewesen sein?
Und warum, und warum hat der Typ ne Rüstung an?
Warum hat der Typ ne Rüstung an und schaut keiner an?
Die haben echt Dachschaden.
Oh Mann.
Das Lachanfall über Rotikklub Gas der Kassenbobel, oh ne, das ist RTL, das guck ich mir nachher an.
Der Typ ist auch geil.
Das ist doch der, den sie irgendwie fragen,
auf welchem Platz wird irgendwie ihre Fußballmannschaft landen und er sagt dann, ja,
ja, alle.
Jetzt hast du es ab heute sind die deine Recommendation. Scheiße, ja, 100% Viewtime.
Na ja, gut, wo fangen wir an?
Btf, ich rauch nicht, ich hab keine Erkältung, nix, aber
erst mal husten.
Warum auch immer.
Mondschutz ist auf.
Rauchen nicht, aber kiffen, das auch nicht, aber ich bin dafür, dass sie den Scheiß legalisieren.
Ich verstehe den Sinn nicht,
warum
ein normaler Schnaps, Zigaretten und sonst was legal ist.
Aber jemand, der joint rauchen will, ist irgendwie übelster Schwerverbrecher. Das leuchtet mir nicht ganz ein. Hast du Heuschnupfen? Nö.
Auch nicht. Ich war, ich war sechs Wochen nicht draußen, Alter. Woher soll ich Heuschnupfen haben?
Ich hab seit sechs Wochen Homeoffice, ich war nicht einmal, nein das stimmt nicht.
Jetzt habe ich übertrieben, ja.
Ich war selten auf der Straße, aber ich kann es eigentlich nirgendswoher haben.
Lüftest du? Ja, das stimmt, mache ich. Nee, nee, nee, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich lüfte nicht, ich lüfte nicht, ich
nehme den Lüftungsmodus von meiner Klimaanlage und der hat einen Pollenfilter.
Excellent, also, Make Windows look better, elegant look.
It's 2020.
Easy windows 10 customization.
Ja, warum soll man Windows Better locken lassen?
Hey Max, ich möchte mir ein eigenes, übrigens Leute denkt dran, wenn ihr, wenn ich nicht
in Chat gucke, ihr müsst da add mein Name, also add Wublos davor schreiben, weil dann
habe ich hier nämlich ein Tool laufen, was die Sachen mitlockt, die an Fragen kommen,
die ich übersehe.
Ansonsten sehe ich sie nicht.
Wenn ich sie nicht sehe, direkt dann, Battlefield zum Start, können wir machen, ich habe sogar
ein Battlefield-Video auf hier, best, oh ne, Moment, jetzt haben wir kein Battlefield-Video,
ich habe irgendwo ein Battlefield-Video offen gehabt, ah das hier, das da, achso ja die
Frage, Vinide, ich weiß nicht, ob das so stimmt, Silvertag, 4 Monate, huge sub, mega
big brain subscription, dankeschön für den sub, so, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, Vinide,
genau also, hey Max, ich möchte mir ein eigenes NAS, einen eigenen NAS Server bauen, kannst
du eine Seite empfehlen, wo Systeme vorgeschlagen werden, beziehungsweise wie Computer-Base
für Gaming-PCs, ja, also es gibt für NAS, ich könnte dir auf Reddit ein paar empfehlen,
es gibt Data-Horder, wobei das die extrem Variante ist, Data-Horder ist ein ganz gutes
Subreddit, die haben ganz gute Server-Tests immer für den Heimbereich, die kannst du
dir angucken, und was haben wir dann sonst noch als Reddit, Homelab, genau, ja, hat er
recht, Homelab ist auch ein ganz gutes, Self-hosted ist auch ein gutes Reddit, das stimmt, das
hatten wir auch schon ein paar mal auf hier, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob du da ein komplett
fertiges Bild finden wirst, du musst dir glaube ich ursprünglich mal fragen, also die eigentliche
Frage, die du stellen musst, erst mal, bevor du dir den Kram anguckst, was du damit, was
dein Ziel damit ist, also sprich willst du einfach nur möglichst billig, möglichst
viel Speicher haben, sind dir Verschlüsselungen und irgendwelche Ausfälle und so erst mal
egal, also reicht das, wenn man das innerhalb von einem Tag wieder zum Laufen kriegt oder
willst du, dass es bei einem Festplatten-Ausfall direkt weiterläuft, ohne Datenverlust, ohne
Probleme, dementsprechend sind da unterschiedliche Sachen, die du dir holen musst, einfach Winnie,
excellent, beobachte mich, gib mir Aufmerksamkeit, bock, hat funktionieren, da musst du, du musst
Channel Points verwenden, dann sehe ich das, so, also wo soll man jetzt hier stehen bleiben,
Sniper vs.
Tanks, ich will mir vorher, ich will mir vorher diese Make Windows Look Better angucken, weil
die meisten Videos dieser Art sind kompletter Blödsinn, allerdings hat das gute Bewertung,
mach mal nice, ja mache ich, wenn da ein Sub reinkommt, dann ist das nice, dann drücke
ich auch nice, erst mal nur Runde Sellout starten, jetzt werden die Channel Points gerade
rausgehauen, werde mich mal mit dem Thema befassen, ja, das ist immer am besten, wenn
man sich das in Ruhe, wenn man da jetzt keine große Eile hat, dass man morgen irgendwas
braucht, sich in Ruhe damit beschäftigt, ein paar Posts liest und sich erst mal überlegt,
was man braucht, aber ich, also, wenn du jetzt keine allzu übertriebenen Anforderungen
an dein Nass hast, also, du kommst damit schon mit 300, 400 Euro gut aus, ohne, ohne je nachdem
wie viele Platten du willst, ohne Platten, ja, also, ich hab hier für 250 Euro so ein ganz
billig Ding zusammengebaut und dafür war es auch gerade noch eine 10G Karte, alter, was
ist denn heute los, eine 10G Karte von Ebay drinne, aber, damit kann ich jetzt natürlich
auch keine großen Sprünge machen, wann kommt auf Git eigentlich das aktuelle Streamtool,
ich hab da bis jetzt noch nichts geplant, das funktioniert für mich gerade mal gut
genug.